[Musique]
il chante en fait dans les douches je ne
nous rase pas la tête nous sommes à moitié ravis
que vous vous remettiez juste d'un rhume
nous sommes des sœurs je ne les trouve pas
Anna joie attends j'ai vérifié toute la maison
ils ne sont pas  ici papa il y a ce camping-car et
ils jouaient dessus tout
pensait qu'il y avait quelqu'un à l'intérieur du
détective Loki l'objectif je vais
trouver tes filles
tu mets ces filles sur mes rochers je sais que
tu as cette personne il perd la
garde jusqu'à ce que mon  le téléphone de la fille
nous étions en attente pendant 48 heures il se termine demain à
moins que nous ne portions des accusations ce qui est difficile
pour vous quelque chose
que ce garçon n'a jamais eu de problèmes pas un
jour de sa vie
eh bien cette chose est pittoresque je commencerais à
chercher dans les bois près de l'aire de repos
la police a dit qu'ils le laissaient partir
aujourd'hui six jours et chaque jour elle se
demande pourquoi je ne suis pas là ça nous dit
que tu pourrais nous protéger de
tout ce que
tu as à l'ail